[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم واهلا بكم في حصاد الليله
معكم محمد كريشان في هذه اللحظات عواصم
ومدن في العالم تعيش على وقع احداث مميزه
البدايه من العاصمه الروسيه موسكو
والاعلان على العثور على الصندوقين
الاسودين للطائر التي تحطمت شمال موسكو
وعلى متنها قائد
والى العاصمه النيجيريه النيامي حيث امهل
وزير الخارجيه المعين من قبل قاده
الانقلاب امهل السفيره الفرنسيه لدى
النيجر 48 ساعه لمغادره البلاد
والى نيويورك وتحديدا مقر الامم المتحده
ومن هناك حضرت المنظمه الدوليه من ان
الحرب والجوع يهددان بتدمير السودان
بالكامل
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
العثور على الصندوقين لطائره بريجوجل وبدء
فحص الحمض النووي للجثث وموسكو ترفض
اتهامات غربيه بالتورط باسقاطها الكريملين
يتحفظ على التعليق بشان مستقبل فاغنث
ويلزم المجموعات غير النظاميه بقسم الولاء
وبلاروسيا تؤكد بقاء معظم القوات على
اراضيها
ساعات بعد اول عمليه انزال اوكراني في
القرم منذ ضمها من روسيا شبه الجزيره
تتعرض لهجوما باكثر من اربعين مسيره
والقوات الروسيه تقول انها تصدت للهجوم
وفي اوديسا قصف روسي بالصواريخ كريبر
في تصعيد للتوتر بين نيامي وباريس النيجر
السفير الفرنسيه يومين لمغادره البلاد
ورسائل لقاده الانقلاب الخيار العسكري لا
يزال مطروحا لكن لم يفوت الاوان للتسويه
السلميه و واشنطن توفد مساعده وزير
خارجيتها للمنطقه وتحذر من عرقله الانقلاب
للحرب على الارهاب
معارك تحتدم في ام درمان الجيش السوداني
يعلن تصديه لهجمات جديده من الدعم على مقر
سلاح المدرعات وطالبوا بفتح ممر امن
للمدنيين في نياله جنوب دارفور والسفير
الامريكي بالخرطوم يدعو لانهاء الصراع
ونقل السلطه ويقول ان اطراف القتال اثبتت
عدم اهليتها للحكم
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصات
الرقميه كنا ناقشنا معكم التطورات الجاريه
في النيجر وذلك مع امهال السفير الفرنسي
48 ساعه لمغادره البلاد فضلا عن تفويض
ميامي لكل من بوركينا فاسو ومالي بالتدخل
العسكري الى جانبها تزامنا مع اتصالات
دوليه واقليميه حديثه بشان الازمه
لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد
طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي والسؤال يقول
في ضوء الحركه الدبلوماسي وتفويض مالي
وبوركينا فاسو الى اين تتجه الازمه
الاجابات جاءت على النحو التالي 30% قالوا
ان الازمه تتجه نحو حلا دبلوماسي
[موسيقى]
بما راى 33%
رجحوا تزايد احتمالات التدخل العسكري
فيما راى 37% ان الازمه ستراوح مكانها دون
حل واضح
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر حاليا على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضاء مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
ودوليا
[موسيقى]
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
السلطات المحليه في اقليم البنجاب
الباكستاني تجلي مئه الف قروي وتحذر من
فيضان محتمل في عده انهار وقنوات مائيه
[موسيقى]
اعلن المحققون الروس اليوم العثور على جثث
الضحايا العشره الذين قتلوا في تحطم
الطائره التي كانت تقل قائد مجموعه
اضافه الى الصندوقين الاسودين للطائره وقد
نفى الكريم ضلوعه في الحادث معتبرا ان ذلك
كذب محض وبعد اقل من 48 ساعه على خروجين
من المعادله اصدر الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين مصدورا مرسوما عفوا يلزم عناصر
المجموعات غير النظاميه مثل فاجنر باداء
قسم اليمين
فصول مقتليه لم تتكشف كامله بعد ولم يقل
اللاعبون الاساسيون في هذا الملف جل ما
لديهم الرئيس البيلاروسي الكسندر
لوكاشينكو كشف انه تلقى معلومات بدايه
العام الحالي عن التحضير لمحاوله اغتيال
واضاف انه ابلغ بالامر دون ان يكشف لا
مصدر التهديد ولا مصدر المعلومات واكد
لوكاشينكو ان بوتين لا يمكن ان يكون وراء
سقوط الطائره
تلقيت معلومات جاده للغايه من مصادر مطلعه
عن تحضيرات
وفي غضون ساعتين ارسلت هذه المعلومات الى
بوتين برساله مشفره بعد مرور بعض الوقت
اتصلت
وتاكدت منه هل وصلت اليه تلك المعلومات ام
لا فاكد بريكوجين ان الرئيس الروسي نقل له
هذه المعلومات
اهميه كلام الرئيس البيلاروسي تكمن في
الدور الذي لعبه بعد محاوله التمرد التي
قادها في روسيا قبل شهرين انذاك دخل في
وساطه بين الكرملين افضت الى اتفاق بنقل
عناصر الى قاعده عسكريه بيلاروسيا قرب
منسك وبعد ان خرج بريكوجين من الصوره اعلن
لوكاشينكو وهو حليفه الكرملين المقرب ما
قد يكشف مصير الالاف من مقاتل المجموعه
فالقوام الرئيسي لفاجنر باقي في الاراضي
البيلاروسيه كما قال وان دعت الحاجه فقد
يتم استخدام المزيد منهم بحسب لوكاشينكو
في الاثناء تقول الولايات المتحده ان خطر
المجموعه ما زال قائما وان التقييم مستمر
لبحث تداعيات ما حدث على عملها لاسيمه في
القاره الافريقيه
ومعنى من موسوسلاف ميتراكوفيتش الباحث
والمحلل السياسي اهلا وسهلا بك هل نتوقع
تحقيقا شفافا بعد الحصول على الصندوقين
الاسودين
نامل لتحقيق جيد لكن بصراحه فان التاريخ
يقترحوا امثله عده حيث حصل فيها تحطم غامض
للكثير من الطائرات حيث هنالك رجال مهمين
من النساسه من رجال الاعمال من الثوار
ايضا هم خسروا حياتهم في حوادث وظروف
غامضه في بعض الاحيان حتى بعض عقود لم
يتضح ما الذي حدث فعلا معا اشخاص مثلا
بالقرب
برايس مثلا اي شركه قد يعتبر انه اغتال من
اجل ربما عقد اتفاقيات مع الاتحاد
السوفيتي ربما نفس الشيء حصل مع بريجوجن
حتى ربما بعد عقود قد تمر قد يكون هنالك
العديد من النظريات التي تشرح ما الذي
يحدث النظريات قد لا تعتمد على اد له
واضحه
ودامغه لكن ربما على قد يكون هنالك
مقاربات اجيولوجيه مع اشخاص يؤمنون بها
يعني اذا ترجح ان يستمر الغموض
في هذه المساله
انه سيكون هنالك الكثير من المقاربات اجل
الاشخاص الذين هم ضد بوتين يزعمون ويقولون
انه كان وراء مقتل بريكوجي لكن بالاشخاص
الذين يدعمون بوتين في روسيا فان الامر هو
ربما يمثل
اظهارا وعرضا للاراده السياسيه قال بوتين
انه لا يمكن مسامحه اي شخص
لتنظيمه
لتنظيمه ربما انقلاب في روسيا بالتاكيد
بالتاكيد علينا ان ننتظر حتى نعرف بعض
التفاصيل التقنيه لكن حتى مع كشف هذه
التفاصيل اعتقد ان هنالك سيظل غموض يلف
هذه القضيه والكثير من القصص حتى لو ظهرت
ادله دامغه ان السلطات الروسيه لم يكن لها
ايد في هذا الحدث حتى مع ذلك فان ربما
وسائل الاعلام الغربيه ستلقي اللوم على
روسيا وهذا هو السير طبيعي للاحداث كان
لافتا ما قاله الرئيس بيلاروسي من انه علم
بمحاوله اغتيال وابلغ بوتين وبوتين ابلغ
اليس في ذلك محاوله لابعاد اي شكوك عن
بوتين
ربما ربما هذه هي الطريقه
لابعاد الرئيس بوتين عن اي شبهه وايضا هي
طريقه الرئيس بيلاروسيا من اجل انقاذ ماء
يوجهه كما تعرفون ان الاشخاص وخاصه
المقربين في روسيا يقولون ان رئيس
بيلاروسيا قال انه لن يحدث اي شيء
لبريكوجين وانه كان باستطاع وانه قال انه
سيضمن امنه وسلامته والان كلمته لا تعني
شيء مره اخرى
يريد ان يبعد ان يشبهه عن بوتين وعن نفسه
ايضا بالنسبه حسب رايي بعد ايام من الان
فان التركيز ربما والانتباه لن يكون فقط
عما قتل بريكوجين او ما حدث مع بريكوجين
لكن التركيز سيكون على ما اذا كان هيكل
ادفاجنر ستتاثر
وهل سيمكن ضمها الى الجيش
هل ستقاتل في اوكرانيا ام لا هل ستكون
ناجحه في افريقيا ام لا هل سيتم استبدالها
ربما بهيكله او ميليشيا اخرى هذه هي
الاسئله المهمه وهذه هي الاسئله التي هي
اهم قتل حتى بعد مرور 50 عاما سنستمر طرح
الاسئله وقد لا يتوفر السؤال الجو عفوا
الجواب صحيح عند اي شخص شكرا لك
من موسكو
وبمسرع مالك شركه يغيب ابرز وجوهما تعرف
بشركات الامن الخاص في العالم وقد تحولت
في السنوات الاخيره الى جيوش رديفه للدول
في حروبها ويثير نشاط هذه الشركات القائم
على المرتزقه جدلا قانونيا واخلاقيا
متعاظما خصوصا لجهه عدم خضوعها لاي ضوابط
او حتى مسائله
بندقيه بلا قضيه ليست كتلك التي خلقت
ليحملها رجال فيعيشون عظماء فوق الارض او
عظاما تحتها على ما يصف كتاب التحرر
الوطني بل البندقيه للبيع معلنه بغير
استحياء في سوق مقاولات حروب يتسع
الا احد اكثر وجوهها صخبا منذ برز في حرب
اوكرانيا الاخيره مثل قائد عسكري رسمي
يتحدث باسم فاجنر ويخاطب الشعب الروسي
شاتما القياده العسكريه الروسيه كاشفا ما
وصفها باخطاء قاتله في اداره الحرب قبل ان
يزله زلته الكبرى ويوجه البندقيه نحو
موسكو انها المدينه التي صعد فيها سلم
المال والشهره فوق كومه البنادق الهجينه
على مراى من الرئيس بوتين وبمباركه الكريم
وجهاز الاستخبارات
ليظهر اخيرا من مكان مفترض في افريقيا
وايضا في قيم التحرر والاستقلال واذ طارق
التحليلات في تفكيك مشهد السقوط الاخير
بحثا عن المستفيد وصولا للفاعل فان راس
فاجنر الذي قطع وفقا للتعبير الرائج لن
ينهي ظاهره المستشريه بعدما تجاوز العالم
في سلوك شديد الواقعيه قبولها الى التعايش
بل التطبيع معها والمرتزقه قديمون في
التاريخ لكن وجودهم ودورهم في الحروب ظل
فعلا مستنكره ينظر اليه برايبه وازدراء
ناكرين على اصحابه
رهن حياتهم بالقتال من اجل المال حتى اخذت
شكلها المؤسس فصار لها اسم ومجالس عسكريه
ومراكزه ورؤساءه بربطات عنق او بالذات
عسكريه يعملون بلا قوانين واضحه ناظمه مع
سكوت المجتمع الدولي عدم مطالبات متفرقه
من الامم المتحده بايجاد معاهده حول ما
يسمى شركات الامن الخاص وقد تضخمت وصارت
جيوشا رديفه تتدخل في اي مكان
وقد كان الولايات المتحده التي تخرج منها
اليوم اصوات تلعن فاجنر وافعالها السبقه
بانتاجها الاشهر بلاك ووتر متبوعه
بسلالتها المتخفيه بعد وصمها بفضائع خصوصا
في افغانستان والعراق ويمكن لحادثه مثل ما
توثق بمججره ساحه النسور في بغداد قبل 15
عاما والتي وصلت الى القضاء الامريكي ان
تكون علامه لا تنسى في تاريخ هذه
المجموعات اذ خرج اخر المتهمين بقتل 14
عراقيا بعفوا من الرئيس الامريكي نفسه
يمكن لبروغاجين ورفاقه ايغيب الى الابد
وتبقى قصتهم ماده ثريه لدراما تصور حياه
المغامرين والمقامرين في افلام المافيا
الاثره لكن ما يحدث على الارض ليس خيالا
بل دماء حقيقيه في حروب ملت بسه فللحرب
قوانين واذ لا تستطيع الجيوش النظاميه
كسرها فقد تكفل العقل السياسي باستيلادي
من يكمل المهمه من خارج القانون قولا
وفعلا
ومعنى من ماتشات العقيده المتقاعد البخاري
محمد مؤمل الخبير في القضايا الامنيه
والاستراتيجيه وشان الافريقي اهلا وسهلا
بك هل تعتقد بان الدول التي ارتبطت الدول
الافريقيه طبعا التي ارتبطت تشعر الان
ببعض القلق
لا اقول بانها تشعر
بقلق المشاهدين ولا شك بانها تطرح
التساؤلات
وخاصه الدول التي
دورن اساسي في امنها او على الصح عمل
الانظمه الحاكمه فيها واخص بالذكر وسط
جمهوريه وسط افريقيا
وجمهوريه مالي وكذلك
لا يقتصر يقتصر وجودها على هذه الدول
الثلاثه بالله وجودا اخر لانها ليست فقط
مؤسسه مؤسسه عسكريه هي اول ما قبل كل شيء
مؤسسه اقتصاديه لانها تعمل وتستثمر
باستخراج واستغلال المعادن وخاصه المعادن
الثمينه مثل الذهب وكذلك النفط نراها
تستغله الذهب في مالي ويبدو ان ايضا
تستغله في السودان
بالتحالب او التعاون التامر سموها مشيئتهم
مع قوات الدعم السريع اذا لا شك لان الدول
التي لفقنا فيها وجود تطرح تساؤلات حول
مصير العلاقه ونوعها وخاصه بانر سوف يتغير
الكثير في بنيتها وفي رؤيتها وبدا ذلك
التغير من
باعلان الرئيس الروسي مرسوما جديدا يكلف
المؤسسات العسكريه ايا كان نوعها باليمين
باليمين يعني بان الدوله الروسيه ستكون
لها سلطه وقوه مراقبه على المؤسسات
الخصوصيه وخاصه التي سبق ان شهدت ان عاش
البلده
تمردا هي صاحبته يعني عفوا عفوا هذه
التساؤلات يعني بعد بعد اذنك هذه
التساؤلات التي طرحتها هل يمكن ان تصل الى
حد
كشف بعض الفضائح لان هناك توجه في روسيا
ربما للاشاره لبعض الفساد في الصفقات
المتعلقه ببروجيج بريجوجن هذا يمكن ان
يمتد لقاده افارقه خاصه في المسائل التي
ذكرتها قبل قليل
لا لا شك لا شك بان يكون هنالك كشف فضائح
ولكن من الطرف الذي سيعلن تلك الفضائح
ويكشفها انا اتوقع بانه ان يكون من خصوم
روسيا اكثر ما هو من الدوله لان
الذين يصفونها بالارزاق ويصبونها بالاجرام
ويصفونها بالارهاب ليست الدوله الروسيه
وانما الغرب الولايات المتحده وحلفائها في
فضائح الا ان اشكال الفضائح على هذا
المستوى لا يمكن ان تقتصر على مؤسسه وحدها
بل ربما يكون لبعض السلطات في الحكومه
الروسيه طالعه وهذا ما يجعله حدا قويا
لكشف تلك الفضائح هو ملف اظنه متواصل سوف
نكتشفه الكثيره من حيثياته وسيبقى الكثير
ايضا مخفيه شكرا جزيلا لك العقيده
المتقاعد البخاري محمد مؤمل من نواكشوط
[موسيقى]
انتبهوا جزيره القرم ساحه مواجهه تتسع
فبعد ساعات قليله من تنفيذ القوات
الاوكرانيه اول عمليه انزال من نوعها على
سواحل شبه الجزيره اعلنت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه عن اسقاط اكثر من اربعين مسيره
اوكرانيا حاولت مهاجمه القرم بشكل متزامن
فجر الجمعه كما اسقطت الدفاعات الجويه
الروسيه صاروخ اس 200 كان متجها الى منطقه
كالوجا التي تبعد حوالي 160 كيلومترا عن
العاصمه موسكو
شبه جزيره القرم في المعنى استراتيجي
العسكري تحولت الى نقطه ساخنه للمره
الاولى ربما منذ ضمها لاراضي روسيا عام
خلال 24 ساعه هجمتها القوات الاوكرانيه
باكثر من 70 طائره مسيره الضربه الاكبر
تمت فجر الجمعه بحسب وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
باكثر من اربعين طائره سبقها هجوم باكثر
من 30 مسيره اخرى اسقطت القوات الروسيه
معظمها بالتشويش الالكتروني خبراء يقراون
كثافه الهجمات الاوكرانيه على القرم تبدلا
في تكتيكات الهجوم المضاد تكتيكات تعتمد
على تكثيف الهجمات كما ونوعا كما حدث مع
ما اعلنته كييف من تنفيذ وحدات تابعه لها
انزالا وصفته بالناجح على شبه الجزيره
بينما اكدت روسيا انها احبطت الهجوم وقتلت
جميع افراد القوات المهاجمه التطور
الميداني هذا يضاف اليه ضربه غير معتاده
على منطقه كالوجا
الاستهداف تم بصاروخ من طراز 200 معدل
بحسب مقاله موسكو يمكن للصاروخ المعدل ان
يطير لمسافه تصل الى 400 كيلومتر هذا يعني
انه انطلق على الارجح من مناطق في شمال
شرقي كييف خطوره الاستهداف ليس ان كالوجا
قريبه من موسكو بل لانها مركز لابرز
الصناعات الثقيله المدنيه الروسيه فهي
تعتبر مقرا لصناعه وتجميع السيارات
والعربات والسكك الحديديه
القراءه هذه قد تقود الاستنتاج ان
اوكرانيا تتجه الى تكثيف نوعيه هجماتها في
العمق الروسي فان لم تصب هذه الضربات
اهدافها فقد يكون كافيا في هذه المرحله
باوكرانيا ان تربك الداخل الروسي
[موسيقى]
كبير الخبراء العسكريين في مؤسسه
للدراسات اهلا وسهلا بك هل من تفسير لعوده
شبه جزيره القرم
للواجهه عسكريا الان
لكلا الجانبين فان القرن وربما يتم وصفها
على انها مركز جاذبيه بالنسبه للروس هي
جزء من الاراضي المحتله التي
سيدفعون ثمنا غاليا للحفاظ عليها وانا لا
اقول انهم لن يتخلوا عنها وايضا بالنسبه
للاوكرانيين هي الهدف الاهم بالنسبه لهم
تحدثوا دائما عن استعاده القرم بالتالي
لكلا الجانبين هي ربما الجبهه الاهم وهذا
الامر يعكسه ان حقيقه انها ربما هي
المنطقه التي يدافع عنها بشكل اكبر في
اوروبا بالاضافه الى كيف طبعا الروس ضموا
شبه الجزيره منذ 2014 هل معنى ذلك ان
تحصيناتهم هناك افضل بكثير من شرق
اوكرانيا الذي احتلوه مؤخرا
اعتقد ان معظم المراقبين الان ليس فقط في
الغرب لكن في كل انحاء العالم سيقولون ان
خطوط الدفاع الروسيه والخنادق هي تصد
والهجمات في المستقبل المنظور ليس فقط في
لكن في زبالوجيا بالنسبه لدفاعات القرن
الان
فهي الاكثر فعاليه هي دفاعات الجويه
بالتالي يقول الروس انه يجب عليه انهم
يقوموا باسقاط الهجمات المسيرات
الاوكرانيه بالتالي نعم القرن يتم الدفاع
عنها بشكل جيد الان لان هذا قيمه عاليه
للروس وللاوكرانيين ايضا ولكن بالنسبه
للاوكرانيين هل بمقدورهم الموازنه بين
جبهه الشرق وجبهه شبه جزيره القرم
هذا سؤال مهم الامريكيون
تم انتقادهم من قبل
اوكرانيا وهذا امر جديد ليس علنا لكن ربما
تحت خلف الابواب المغلقه في فشلهم في
تركيز هجومهم على محور واحد يقول
الامريكيون وربما هم محقين ان هذا المحور
يجب ان يكون باتجاه القرن عن طريق زبروجيا
بالتالي ما قامت به اوكرانيا هو نشر
قواتها خارج على ثلاث محاور وليس على محور
واحد كلا الجانبين هم لديهم قوات قليله
على الارض اذا خطوط القوات منتشره بشكل
كبير بالتالي نحن
نواجه فتره جمود الان حيث ان لن يتمكن ايا
من الطرفين من احراز اي مكاسب شكرا جزيلا
لك
[موسيقى]
الان الى النيجر فبعد طلب المجلس العسكري
لقاده الانقلاب من السفير الفرنسي في نيام
المغادره خلال مهله اقصها 48 ساعه ردت
الخارجيه الفرنسيه بالقول لا سلطه
للانقلابيين في النيجر تسمح لهم بطلب
مغادره سفيرنا وقد تجمع متظاهرون امام
القاعده العسكريه في مطار النيامي ورددوا
هتافات تطالب القوات الفرنسيه بالرحيل من
البلاد كما ندد المتظاهرون بفرنسا
وبالتدخل المحتمل لدول الاكواس معربين عن
تاييدهم للمجلس العسكري الحاكمي في البلاد
وكان ما يطلق على نفسه المجلس الوطني
لحمايه الوطن قد اعلن بدايه الشهر الحالي
انهاء اتفاقيات التعاون العسكري مع باريس
في هذه الاثناء قال عمر علي توري رئيس
مفوضيه المجموعه الاقتصاديه لدول غرب
افريقيا اكواس قال ان المجموعه لم تعلن
الحرب على شعب النيجر وليس لديها خطه لغزو
البلاد موضحا ان اللجوء الى خيار استخدام
القوه في النيجر لا يزال مع ذلك مطروحا
على الطاوله
بين نذر الحرب ودعوات الدبلوماسيه تتارجح
الازمه في النيجر على مشارف انقضاء شهرها
الاول مجموعه ايكواس تتصدر لانقلاب
والملوحين على مدار اسابيع بالتدخل
العسكري لاعاده الرئيس المحتز محمد بازوم
لمنصبه وبينما اكدت انباء سابقه ان قاده
جيوش ايكواسام ملامح التدخل المفترض يصرح
الجمعه رئيس مفوضيه المجموعه الا خطه
لديهم للغزو وان كل السبل مفتوحه لاستعاده
النظام الدستوري غير مستبعد للخيار
العسكري
يؤكد هنا ان الجماعه الاقتصاديه لدول غرب
افريقيا لم تعلن الحرب على شعب النيجر
وليس لديها خطه للغزل كما ان الجهود
مستمره للتعاون مع قاده الانقلاب في
النيجر من اجل التوصل الى حل ودي
رئيس نيجيريا بولا احمد تينيبو الذي يتراس
الدوره الحاليه لاكواس قال انه تلقى
اتصالات كثيره من دول بالمجموعه بشان
جهوزيه قواتها للمشاركه في التدخل بالنيجر
مضيفا انه يعمل على ثني اكواس وغيرها عن
هذا الخيار
تصريحات الرئيس النيجيري جاءت بعد استماعه
لوفد العلماء الذين اوفدهم لنيامي مجددا
للقاء قاده الانقلاب الذين رحبوا سابقا
بتلك الوساطه قاده الانقلاب من جهتهم
اعلنوا تفويض قوات مالي وبوركينا فاسو
لدخول النيجر ان تعرضت لهجوم رحبت خارجيه
البلدين بالقرار لمواجهه ما وصفته
بالعدوان المحتمل الذي تخطط له ايكوس التي
تضم الدول الثلاث جميعا
لا تقتصر دائره التدخل على هذا فقط
فللزائر جاره الشمال موقفها المعلن ضد
التدخل وزير خارجيتها يزور نيجيريا وغانا
ووفدها في نيامي يحذر من تبعات كارثيه لاي
تدخل عسكري
[موسيقى]
نحن ممن يرفضون اي تدخل عسكري في النيجر
لما له من تبعات كارثيه نسخ النيجر وحسب
بل في دول المنطقه ايضا ولهذا نعمل ونسعى
ونبذل جهودنا من اجل ايلاء الاولويه
لمقاربه سياسيه تفاوضيه
تقع النيجر ايفان بين محيط غير متفق على
التعاطي مع ازمتها فبينما تكرر اكواس
التلويح بالتدخل العسكري ولو كاحد
الخيارات تنبعث من بين دول المجموعه
تحذيرات حاده ضد هذا الخيار وصولا الى
التلويح بالمواجهه العنيفه ومن الجزائر
شمالا يتعزز الرفض وان كان من خارج ايكواس
ولكنه عالي النبره لتراوح نيجيريا جنوبا
بين استحقاقات رئاستها الدوريه
ومساعي رئيسها نحو الحلول الدبلوماسيه
نيجيريا ستكون احدى محطات جوله افريقيه
لمساعده وزيره الخارجيه الامريكي للشؤون
الافريقيه
وستكون ازمه النيجر على جدول اعمالها وفق
بيان الخارجيه الامريكيه الذي ذكر انها
ستشدد على ضروره الحفاظ على الديمقراطيه
واطلاق سراح الرئيس المحتجز وافراد اسرته
ومعلم الباريس
الباحث في المعهد الاوروبي للاستشراف
والامن اهلا وسهلا بك بعد ان قالت باريس
انها لن تدعن لقرار طرد السفير الفرنسي لا
تعترف بذلك ماذا عساها تفعل
اذا لم يكن يدري بان السؤال موجه اليه
الان هو موجه اليه
في الحقيقه هناك تصعيد نشهده في العلاقات
التي اصلا هي سيئه بين فرنسا الدوله
الاستعماريه السابقه والنيجر لانه هناك
طلب
بمغادره اسافير الفرنسي كيفيه تفسير ذلك
بطرق مختلفه اما ان هذا تحذير قبل
الانتقال الى مرحله
لاحقه التي ستكون الضربه الاقصى لفرنسا
الا وهي طرد
القوات العسكريه الفرنسيه الموجوده في
قاعده في النيجر والتي
تضم اكثر من 1500 جنديه هي من القاعدتين
العسكريتين الفرنسيهتين الاساسيتين مع
قاعده جيبوتي لماذا هذا التصعيد ولماذا
ربما هذا
اذا التواعد لان فرنسا ترفض الاعتراف
بالسلطات الجديده لا تزال فرنسا تعتبر ان
هناك حكومه
مشروعه تم الانقلاب عليها بالقوه وفرنسا
تقبل بذلك وبالتالي يحدوها املهم بانه من
خلال ممارسه الضغوطات
الضغط باحتمال التدخل العسكري ضغوطات
اقتصاديه ضغوطات ديبلوماسيه اذا مع كل هذه
العناصر تامل فرنسا ان ترغم الانقلابيين
على الخضوع ولكنهم يرفضون ذلك وسوف نرى
كيف سينتهي هذا ولكن سيكون هناك خاسر الا
اذا توصلنا الى حل ديبلوماسي ولكن عدا عن
ذلك اما ان الانقلابيين العسكريين سوف يتم
الانقلاب عليهم والا سوف تخسر فرنسا كثيرا
لان النيجر فيه
القاعده العسكريه الفرنسيه وهذا امر بالغ
الاهميه بالنسبه لفرنسا في الساحل في
قتالها ضد الارهاب وهناك ايضا سلاح اخر
بايديا العسكريين وهي الاتفاق لتصدير
اليورانيوم من النيجر هناك مواجهه هناك
تصعيد مما يستمر ويكون هناك خاسر ام يتم
التواصل الى حل دبلوماسي
والتسويه او تسويه معينه من الطرفين شكرا
جزيلا لك
من باريس
الان من ابو جاد ديفيد اوتو اندلي مدير
مركز جونيف للامن والدراسات الاستراتيجيه
في افريقيا اهلا وسهلا بك السيد
اندلي هذا التصعيد مع فرنسا
اين يمكن ان يصل
انه كان هنالك نوع من الارتياح اليوم
عندما
قال رئيس اكواس بانه
سيكون هنالك وضع اولويات للحوار والطرق
الدبلوماسيه وان الاكواز لا تقول لم تقل
انها سوف تغزو النيجر بل انها سوف تستخدم
فقط التدخل العسكري كملاذ اخير نعرف جيدا
انه بعض السلطات في الجزائر قد اوضحت ان
فرنسا كانت تطلب
تستخدم امكانيه المجال الجوي في امكانيه
التدخل العسكري لكن
الفرنسا انكرت هذا المزعم لكن ما نعرفه
لحل الان ان النيجر تتهيا لاي حدث في حاله
التدخل العسكري وقد قاموا بعقد اتفاق مع
بوركينا بوركينا فاسو ومالي التي يسمح
لهاتين الدولتين بارسال قواتما والتدخل في
حاله اعتداء على النيجر بالتالي نعتقد ان
الحوار هو الذي سيكون حلا نريد ان نرى ايه
صعيد من لوضع سيء في النيجر ولكن اما
وصفته بالارتياح بعد تصريح السيد تراي الا
يمكن اعتباره ايضا تهيئه
وافقاد للمصداقيه في موضوع التدخل العسكري
لانه واضح ان اكواس
تبدو خائفه من هذا الخيار
اعتقد
[موسيقى]
قامت بتقييم الوضع الذي فيه
وايضا
كوارث لم تتلقى اي دعم لمساله تدخل
العسكري اذا ما كان هنالك
دخول او غزو للبلد ولا يكون هنالك ترحيب
شعبي سيكون عمليا انتحاريه بالاضافه الى
ذلك ادركت ان بعض دولها مثل مالي بوركينا
فاسو وغينيا هي ليست مهتمه لدعم الاكواس
في حقيقه الامر هم مهيئون اللي خوض حرب مع
الاكواز اذا ما قامت بغزو النيجر ايضا
واجهت مشكله لانها لا تستطيع ان تقنع دول
تقوم لديها حدود مع النيجر مثل تشاد
والجزائر لكي تقوم بدعمها بالتالي هو
الاكواز في وضع صعب للغايه وخاصه عندما
يدافع عندما قامت رؤساء هيئات الاركان
المشترك المشتركه قاموا باللقاء في غانا
وقالوا وناقشوا هذا الامر بالتالي هذا
تناقض مما
ذكرته القياده انهم لم يكونوا مهيئين
للحرب لكننا راضيين جدا في هذه المرحله ان
الايكو اس تقبلت انها مساله وضع تفضيل
الخيار الدبلوماسيه على التدخل العسكري
شكرا جزيلا لك من
[موسيقى]
الى السودان حيث قال المتحدث باسم الجيش
هناك العميد نبيل عبد الله قال للجزيره ان
الجيش السوداني تمكن من صدد ثلاث هجمات
للدعم السريع على مقر سلاح المدرعات كما
افاد مراسلنا باشتداد المعارك بين الجيش
والدعم السريع في مدن العاصمه الثلاث في
الاثناء قال وكيل الامين العام للامم
المتحده لشؤون الانسانيه مارتن جريفيث ان
مئات الالاف من الاطفال في البلاد يعانون
من سوء التغذيه الحاد ويواجهون خطر الموت
اذا تركوا دون علاج
تستعر معارك الجيش والدعم السريع في
العاصمه السودانيه وولايات دارفور قصف
الجيش بالطائرات الحربيه والمسيره
والمدفعيه الثقيله مواقع الدعم في مدن
العاصمه الثلاث وردد عليه هذه القوات من
مختلف نقاط تمركزيها وذكر ان الطرفين
تبادل اطلاق النار الكثيف على الارض يوم
الجمعه
في هذه الاثناء اعلن الجيش ان قائده رئيس
مجلس السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان يواصل
تفقد مواقع الجيش المختلفه ونشر صورا
وصفها بانها للتفاقد البرهان سلاح
المدفعيه بمدينه عطبره في ولايه نهر النيل
شمالي الخرطوم والجرحى بالمستشفى العسكري
بالمدينه
انعكاسات النزاع واضحه في مختلف الاتجاهات
خارج الخرطوم منظمه اطباء بلا حدود قالت
ان موظفيها في نيالا عاصمه جنوب دارفور
وعشرات الاف المدنيين محاصرون ويعيشون
اوضاعا انسانيه بالغه القسوه في هذه
الاثناء حذرت الامم المتحده مما غبت
تداعيات اتساع دائره الحرب ونزوح وندوء
السكان ووصف منسق المنظمه للشؤون
الانسانيه
نتائج ذلك بالكارثه الانسانيه
يحتوي التقرير على تحذير واضح للمنسق
الشؤون الانسانيه بان الحرب والجوع يمكن
ان يلتهم السودان اذا لم يضع طرفان ازاعي
شعب السوداني فوق السعي للسلطه وتلفت
المنظمه الدوليه الانظار الى ان مئات الاف
الاطفال يعانون من سوء التغذيه الحاد
ويواجهون خطر الموت الوشيك ومع تعثر مختلف
المبادرات الراميه لانهاء النزاع وتوقف
مباحثات الطرفين في جده جدد السفير
الامريكي بالخرطوم نداءات بلاده بوقف
الحرب ونقل السلطه المدنيين لم يقترح
كيفيه حدوث ذلك ولا يعرف طبعا كيف ستجد
دعوته اذان صاريه في غمره العنف الرائن
وانعدام الثقه بين الجانبين في انتظار
نتائج جوله ذكر ان الفريق البرهان سيقوم
بها بعدد من الدول
[موسيقى]
الا رئيس الوزراء وزير الخارجيه القطري
الشيخ محمد بن عبد الرحمن الثاني ان بلاده
توسطت في ملف تبادل السجناء الاخير بين
ايران والولايات المتحده واعرب المسؤول
القطري خلال كلمه له امام المعهد الدولي
للدراسات الاستراتيجيه بسنغافوره عن امله
في ان تقود جهود قطر الى مزيد من الحوار
بشان الملف النووي
الى اتفاق وقد
قلنا الوسطاء في تبادل الاسرى الاخير
وفتحنا قنوات ايضا لغراض انسانيه سوف
تساعدون في حلق حل قضايا
عالقه ونامل بين جهودنا سوف تؤدي الى مزيد
من الحوار حول الملف الدولي
وفي الدوحه التقى قائد القياده الوسطى
الامريكيه مايكل كوريلا بوزير الدوله
القطري لشؤون الدفاع الدكتور خالد العطيه
ورئيس الاركان القطريه الفريق سالم النابت
وقالت القياده الامريكيه الوسطى على منصه
اكس ان اللقاء شهد مناقشه فرص تعميق
الشراكه العسكريه القويه بالفعل بين
الجانبين
اكد وزير الداخليه التركيه علي يرلي كايا
ان حكومه بلاده تكافح الهجره غير النظاميه
وفق القوانين الدوليه وما تقتضيه مصلحه
وامن تركيا واضاف الوزير التركي في حديث
مع جزيره ضمن برنامج لقاء اليوم الذي سيبث
لاحقا ان ما يثار بشان اجبار السوريين على
العوده الى شمال سوريا ليس صحيحا
فيما يتعلق باللجوء غير النظامي فاننا
نطبق ما تقتضيه القوانين من اجل تحقيق امن
شعبنا ورفاهيته واستقراره وهو ما يتضمن
تدابير ارجاع اللاجئين غير النظاميين الى
بلدانهم اقولها بصراحه كل مواطن سوري
يغادر الى الطرف الاخر من الحدود لدينا
ورقه موقعه منه تثبت مغادرته لتركيا
بارادته واؤكد ان كل ما يقال ليس حقيقه
مسلما بها هنالك من يحاول استغلال وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي
وانواع اخرى من الاعلام للاثاره
وزير الداخليه التركيه وصف الذين يتحدثون
بعنصريه وكراهيه للاجانب في بلاده بانهم
هامشيون يتم التعامل معهم في اطار القانون
كما قال
لا يمكننا ان نسمح للعنصريه وكريه الاجانب
التي ليس لها مكان في تاريخنا وثقافتنا
ومعتقداتنا بالانتشار في مجتمعنا فيقوم
المدعون العامون والحقوقيون بما يجب ان
يقوموا به في الوقت المناسب وفي اطار
القوانين واللاسف يوجد في داخلنا بعض
الاشخاص الهامشيين من اصحاب الافكار
الهامشيه ممن يعلنون عداوتهم للاجانب هذه
مشكله من غير الممكن ان نجعل الجميع
يفكرون بالطريقه المثلى والجميله للاسف
هنالك هامشيون نحن نتابعهم ونراهم
ونراقبهم والاهم من ذلك ان المجتمع
التركيه لا يليهم اهميه او قيمه
ندت حركه النهضه التونسيه بما وصفته تعرض
المعتقلين السياسيين للتمكين والاعمال
الصحي والتضيق كما دانت الحركه اعلان
الوزاريا بتعقب اصحاب الراي الحر والمعارض
في كل مكان بما في ذلك الانترنت وفق
تعبيرها وكانت وزارات العدل والداخليه
وتكنولوجيا الاتصال قد حذرت في بيان
المشترك غير مسبوق بملاحقه كل من يساهمه
في نشر محتوى يمسه بمصالح الدوله ويسعى
الى تشويه رموزها كما جاء في نص البيان
المشترك
[موسيقى]
شهدت السويداء جنوبيه سوريه مزيدا من
الاحتجاجات تمديدا بتردي الاوضاع المعيشيه
فقد خرجت مظاهرات مؤيده لمحتجي السويداء
في مدن وبلدات بمحافظه درعا الخضيعه
لسيطره السلطات السوريه وكذلك في ادلب
التي لا تخضع لسيطره النظام
تتواصل احتجاجات السويداء وتدخل اسبوعها
الثاني وقد اكتست زخما جديدا منضمام قرى
وبلدات جديده الى الحراك السلمي وسط
المدينه
مرحله جديده حسب ناشطين تعددت فيها مطالب
المحتجين وارتفع سقفها مع توالي الايام
دعم المرجعيه الدينيه ومشاركتها في
المظاهرات لعب دورا كبيرا في زياده اعداد
المحتجين حسب الاهالي حيث حذرت المرجعيه
الدينيه من التخريب واعمال العنف حفاظا
على الحراك السلميه
في درعا تظاهر الاهالي في بصرى الشامي
وطفس ومناطق اخرى دعما للحراك في السويداء
رغم القبضه الامنيه التي تحكم المنطقه
[تصفيق]
الى شمال سوريا اتسعت رقعه التظاهرات ايضا
لتشمل اكثر من 35 نقطه في ادلب ومحيطها
عبر خلالها المحتجون عن مساندتهم للمحتجين
في السويداء
كما طالب المتظاهرون بالافراج عن
المعتقلين وتطبيق القرارات الدوليه التي
تدعم عمليه الانتقال السياسي في البلاد
ادهم ابو الحسام الجزيره
ادلب
تواصلوا فرق وانقاذ محليه في اقليم
البنجاب الباكستاني تواصل جهودها لنقل
واجلاء قرويين جراء فيضان نهر ستلج الذي
يقول مسؤولون باكستانيون انه نجم عن تصريف
الهند لكميات كبيره من المياه عبر انهار
مشتركه بين البلدين
ثلاثه اسابيع والمياه في اقليم البنجاب
شرقيه باكستان تتدفق الى خارج ضفاف نهري
شيناب وقنوات مائيه تتفرع منهما
ما تسبب وما يزال في مااسن لقرويين
هنا يبكون شقيقا فقد لايام وعثر على جثته
غارقه في مياه الفيضان
[موسيقى]
وهؤلاء يشكون حالهم بعد خساره البيت
والارض
الجميع يستنجد بالحكومه ولكنني اقول لهم
لماذا فقدنا احبائنا وتدمرت مزارعنا
وهجمتنا مياه النهر لتاخذ منا ابناءنا
ومواشينا لن يبقى لنا شيء
تخوفا من فيضان شامل نقلت السلطات مئه الف
من سكان مئات القرى في عده محافظات الى
اراضي مرتفعه بعد غمر بيوتهم والطرق
المؤديه اليها
تعين علينا المغادره بعد طول انتظار علل
المياه تنخفض لكننا اضطررت الى المغادره
وسيبقى زوجي وابني في البيت حتى ينقذ ما
يمكن انقاذه
فيضان اقليم البنجاب شرقيه باكستان حدث
بعد تصريف الهند كميات كبيره من المياه
عبر انهر وقنوات مائيه مشتركه بين البلدين
والخشيه الان من اتساع رقعه المناطق
المتضرره
بالنظر لحجم الفيضاني في اقليم البنجاب
وعدم قدره الانهوري على استيعاب المياه
المتدفقه تخشى سلطاته من اتساع رقعه
المناطق المتضرره لتشمل في مرحله لاحقه
جنوبيه البلاد عبد الرحمن مطر الجزيره
اقليم البنجاب
[موسيقى]
في فقره المتابعه نسلط الضوء على ملف جدده
الجدل بشان شركه فاجنا فلم تعد الحروب
الجديده تعتمد حصرا على الجيوش التقليديه
تساهم شركات امنيه وعسكريه خاصه في الحروب
غير المنظمه والحروب بالوكاله لحساب دول
وحكومات شركه ليست سوى واحده منها فقط في
سوق المرتزقه المزدهر اكثر فاكثر وتعود
جذور شركه فاجنر الروسيه الى شركه اوريل
لمكافحه الارهاب والتي تاسست رسميا في
مدينه اوريول عام 2003 باعتبارها مركزا
للتعليم والتدريب غير الحكوميه وقد انشاها
قاده سابقون في القوات الخاصه السوفياتيه
تضم خريطه نشاطها اوكرانيا سوريا ليبيا
وافريقيا الوسطى وغيرها من الدول هناك
ايضا
الامريكيه الشهيره والتي تاسست عام 1997
وهي شركه عسكريه نفذت عمليات قتل خارج
القانون في العراق وافغانستان وتتولى
حمايه نظام الدفاع الصاروخي الياباني تصف
تقارير جي فور اس باكبر الجيوش الخاصه في
العالم واحده من اكبر شركات الخدمات
الامنيه متعدده الجنسيات وهي بريطانيه
الاصل مقرها الرئيسي في كراولي الواقعه
جنوب لندن وتعمل في اكثر من مئه وخمسه
وعشرين دوله ولديها اكثر من 650 الف موظف
في العالم اما ديفيون انترناشونال ومقرها
ليما عاصمه بيرو فهي شركه تستقطب الالاف
من المقاتلين من الدول الناميه ولديها
مكاتب في الفلبين والسريلانكا والعراق
يتساءل كثيرون عن مفهوم الشركات الامنيه
الخاصه ووضعها القانوني وكذلك علاقتها
بالدول والحكومات التي تعمل لحسابها او
فيها عرفت الامم المتحده شركات الخدمات
الامنيه والعسكريه الخاصه بانها شركات ذات
كيانا قانوني تقدم خدماتا عسكريه ام او
عسكريه وامنيه بواسطه اشخاص طبيعيين او
كيانات قانونيه لقاء مقابلا ماديا يشمل
ذلك التخطيط الاستراتيجي والاستخبارات
والتحقيقات وعمليات الاستطلاع البري او
البحري او الجوي وكذلك عمليات الطيران ايا
كان نوعها والمراقبه بالاقمار الصناعيه
اما الخدمات الامنيه فتتضمن حراسه او
حمايه للمباني والمنشات والممتلكات وكذلك
الاشخاص بواسطه حرس مسلحين واي نوع من
انواع نقل المعارف بواسطه
تطبيقات امنيه او تطبيقات حفظ النظام
واتخاذ تدابير امنيه لاغراض الرقابه
وتنفيذها
هذا التعريف يجعل تعريف المرتزقه الوارد
في الماده الاولى من الاتفاقيه الدوليه
لمناهضه تجنيد المرتزقه واستخدامهم
وتمويلهم الصادره عام
1989 غير منطبقا على موظفي هذه الشركات
اذا ما عملوا بشكل قانوني لان الواقع ليس
دائما على هذه الصوره ويشير مفهوم صناعه
الشركات العسكريه والامنيه الخاصه بصوره
عامه الى شركات تجاريه تبرم عقودا قانونيه
تهدف بالاساس الى تحقيق الربح مقابل ما
تقدمه من خدمات تتعلق بالمجال الامني ينضم
الينا الان من واشنطن السيد شون ماكفيت
الضابط السابق في قوات النخبه الامريكيه
والاستاذ بكليه الدفاع الوطني ومؤلف كتاب
المرتزقه الحديثي الحديثيون او الحديثون
عفوا الجيش الخاصه وماذا تعني للنظام
العالمي اهلا وسهلا بك سيد
الى اي مدى سيستمر هذا الجدل بخصوص
الشركات الامنيه الخاصه
ان التخصيص المتزايد للحروب امرنا متصاعد
بعد الحرب العالميه
الثانيه وهو احدى الظواهر لقرننا والتي تم
التغاضي عنها اعتقد ان مجموعه
قد
نبهت العالم الى نفوذها وقوتها خاصه عندما
اقتربت مون موسكو قبل شهرين لكن في حقيقه
الامر فان المرتزقه هو هو ثاني اقدم مهنه
وايضا كان في افريقيا
وكان هنالك عندما نتحدث عن بلاك ووتر
وايضا التي تم استخدامهم في العراق
وافغانستان وكان مرتزقه والان فاجنر
بالتالي عندما تقوم اكبر دول باكبر جيوش
الولايات المتحده
وروسيا
باستئجارها هؤلاء المرتزقه واستئجار قوتهم
هذا يعني ان الجميع باستطاعته ان يقوم
بذلك هذا يعطي نوع من المرونه للموقف تجاه
المرتزقه الامر سيستمر هو فقط نقطه في خيط
مستمر لا يتمثل الاشكال بالنسبه لهذه
الشركات في مهامها الخارجيه اكثر من
مهامها اذا ما اقتصرت على داخل الدول التي
تنشئها
نعم كان هنالك الكثير من الجدل دعونا لا
ننسى بلاك وتر في عام 2007 قتلت 15 عراقيا
في ساحه النسور في بغداد والمشكله في
المرتزقه ان مساله السلامه والمساءله اذا
ما قامت جنود بهذا الامر سيكون هنالك
محاكمه عسكريه لهم لكن هؤلاء هؤلاء
المتعاقدون فقط اطلق صراحه ويعادوا الى
بيوتهم نفس الشيء مثلا مع فاغنار مثلا في
مالي وجمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى
وسوريا واوكرانيا قاموا بخروقات
خروقات خطيره ضد حقوق الانسان ولم يكن
هنالك اي مساهمه ما لم يتم مسالته من قبل
من وظفاهم هذا الامر يخلق الكثير من الجدل
في العراق وفي افريقيا وفي سوريا وفي
اوكرانيا ايضا غياب المساءله هل هل يعود
الى فراغ قانوني على الصعيد العالمي في
هذه المساله تحديدا
القانون الدولي
كان متخلفا نوعا ما عن التطور الذي شهدته
الذي شهده سوق المرتزق افضل قانون دولي
فيما يتعلق بالمرتزقه يعود الى عام
1977 وهو محدد بشكل كبير وغير دقيق بحيث
ان اي شخص بامكانه ان يفلت من هذا القانون
مثلا كما حصل مع بلاك ووتر وكما حصل مع
فاغنر فان بظهور تلك الشركات فان القانون
الدولي لم يكن يتماشى مع التهديد الذي ظهر
معهم لكن حتى لو كان هنالك قانون دولي جيد
من الذي سيذهب الى اوكرانيا او الى مالي
ويقوم بالقبض على هؤلاء المرتزقه لن تقوم
الامم المتحده بهذا الامر ولن يقم النيتو
بهذا الامر ولا حتى الاتحاد
لن يقم اي شخص او اي جهه بهذا الامر ايضا
المرتزقه بامكانهم ان يطلقوا النار على
قوات الامن الامر يجعل من المستحيل ان يتم
تنظيم هذا الامر وفي الوقت الذي
ان يكون هنالك كما قلت هو اقدم ثاني مهنه
في التاريخ شكرا جزيلا لك
من واشنطن بهذا مشاهدينا الكرام نكون قد
وصلنا الى نهايه هذه الجوله الاخباريه
الحصاد موعدكم يتجدد بعد دقائق معدودات مع
نشره منتصف الليل فحتى ذلك الحين دمتم في
رعايه الله والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]